عاد الملياردير الصيني جاك ما إلى
الظهور أخيرًا هذا الأسبوع في
مقطع فيديو نشرته وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الصينية
وقد ظهر في الفيديو وهو يتحدث إلى
المعلمين في المناطق الريفية في الصين كجزء من
حدث خيري افتراضي ،
لكن لم يتضح من الفيديو أين
هو بالضبط في العالم  يتحدث من
الآن ، لم يُشاهد جاك ما علنًا
منذ أواخر أكتوبر
قبل أن تخرج السلطات عن مسارها ما
كان يمكن أن يكون
أكبر اكتتاب في العالم لمجموعته العملاقة للتكنولوجيا المالية
الآن يقول الخبراء إن جاك ما كان على الأرجح بعيدًا
عن الأنظار بينما
كانت شركاته تحت التنظيم
لكن غيابه الذي امتد لأشهر
أثار تكهنات بأن
الحملة على إمبراطوريته بدأت
بعد أن دعا جاك ما المنظمين
الصينيين علنًا لخنق الابتكار ، وبالنسبة للبنوك المملوكة للدولة في الصين التي
تستشهد بعقلية الرهن ،
فليس من غير المألوف في الصين
أن تعاقب الحكومة هؤلاء بشدة.  الذين
ينتقدون الحزب
على سبيل المثال اختفى قطب العقارات رينزا
تشانغ لعدة أشهر
الماضية  بعد عام من انتقاد طريقة تعامل شي
جينبينغ المزعومة مع الوباء
، سُجن في النهاية لمدة 18 عامًا
بتهم فساد ،
لذا فإن عودة جاك ما هي بالتأكيد
تنفيس للمستثمرين ،
لكن الحملة على إمبراطوريته
لم تبطئ من وتيرتها.
أصدر جزء من مسؤولي الشركات مسودة قواعد
للحد من هيمنة منظمي عمالقة التكنولوجيا في الصين ،
كما أطلقوا
تحقيقًا في علي بابا بسبب
السلوك
الاحتكاري المزعوم.
في أسواق المال
وأكثر من ذلك بكثير ، لكن بكين فقدت
صبرها مع القوة الهائلة
لعمالقة التكنولوجيا لديها والتي تعتبرها بشكل متزايد
تهديدًا للاستقرار السياسي والاقتصادي ،
ما هو واضح الآن هو أن أيام
التنظيم الخفيف لصناعة التكنولوجيا في
الصين
هل انتهت سيلينا وانغ سي إن إن طوكيو